Французькі круасани смакували б не так добре,
якби для їхнього приготування не витрачали так багато  масла.
Утім, нині паризькі пекарі
дедалі більше потерпають через дефіцит вершкового масла.
Коли я замовляю 100 кілограмів, то отримую хіба що половину,
якщо пощастить.
Крім того, я плачУ вдвічі більше, ніж раніше:
вісім євро за палету замість чотирьох. Це божевілля!
Не так давно здавалося, що всього забагато, а тепер у нас - дефіцит масла.
Для споживачів ситуація ще гірша.
У супермаркетах – порожні полиці.
По всій країні виробляється менше молочних продуктів.
А те, що виробляється, іде переважно за кордон, де платять набагато більше.
На світових ринках ціна на масло зросла більш ніж удвічі.
ле французькі супермаркети згодні платити лише
набагато нижчу фіксовану ціну, яку вони погоджують щороку.
Фермери ж переконані, що система фіксованих цін себе вичерпала.
За цих обставин цілком логічно продавати наше масло на світовий ринок.
Якби супермаркети платили відповідну ціну,
в нас не було б цієї кризи з маслом.
Фермери також вважають, що французькі споживачі
мають бути готові платити більше.
Французи завжди вимагають більшого. Вони хочуть екологічно чистого сільського господарства,
вони хочуть знати, що їдять наші корови,
чи вони вільно пасуться і чи ми виконуємо екологічні стандарти.
Втім, все це коштує грошей, і на споживачів
теж має припадати частина цих видатків.
Втім, супермаркети запевняють, що вже цього року сплатили
на 30 відсотків більше за вершкове масло,
а система фіксованих цін все ще має сенс.
Ціни на світових ринках дуже нестабільні.
Ми очікуємо, що вони незабаром впадуть.
Наші фіксовані ціни полегшують фермерам планування
та прогноз витрат і доходів.
Це допомагає підтримувати фермерство.
Звичайно, постачання масла до супермаркетів стабілізується.
Але цей паризький пекар вирішив перестрахуватися.
Під час Різдвяних свят масло - основний інгредієнт.
Воно потрібне для мого марципану, для традиційних тортів,
для кремових начинок. Тож я вже запасаюся маслом,
щоб його вистачило для свят попри можливі перебої.
Ціни на щоденну випічку він вже теж змушений був підвищити.
Відповідно, і різдвяні смаколики подорожчають цього року.
Втім, поки що французів не відлякують додаткові витрати.
Зрештою, смачна випічка - невід'ємна частина їхньої національної ідентичності.